hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the machine-man my oil seems
to be going quickly all probably cuz my
lamp was on during the entire time that
I was talking with a guy the demon I
know where the Zeppelin is it's up in
its way
ah it's up up a bone I threw that bow I
wonder why it is it like all the
inanimate objects reset their position
because it Cheerilee right there
Raj is the way the game engine works ok
to the Zeppelin all of my Swedish
viewers are nah what I just decided to
boom
my eyes go blurry ah these new textures
I don't remember seeing it
okay anyway hello forest of despair
never next forest always of despair
okay barrels couches the cousin of the
chair I suppose I guess I could make a
quick escape if I want to do so let me
just arrange this so that there is a way
to get out real quick pump and then pump
and then okay ah man ah they're not
giving me much tinderboxes what's that
there is a mechanism blocking the door
fine ha Tim deluxe what do we got what
do we got
huh huh huh huh no yes no what's this no
I heard something so listen
they'd go out here nope can't do that
mm-hmm break a frack oh thank you I
could have figured it out
whatever oh it's not really precious
which looks like stuff
friggin narrow whatever it all matter
huh
it's so strong come on can that do it
[Music]
what
come on I need more oh and yeah no no
come here all right and then double
stack oh no not a puzzle no oh there we
go literally is a Zeppelin do are you
kind of main door lover oh okay that's
cool and all you can shut up go that way
and die oh look it's a big thing above
her no oh no thing nothing okay
ah - doodads ah
Oh the light turned up and turn that one
on no okay what did that do emergency
open left side right side main lever
[Music]
okay left side right side main lever ah
come on what the hell was this do
anything to the ride to the ride oh my
goodness
that's the left don't judge me okay that
does nothing he just nothing
okay what does that do did something
yeah huh ah engines out of order
what do I do Thor push four times
honk honk honk honk
then do this dude
come on duck don't mess with me Gobbo
likes doubles like and it oh yeah uh-huh
[Music]
what
was that just just to get out that's all
I needed to do to get it
oh is that no looky I got the rod now
I'm just
okay okay no big deal no big deal okay
okay okay
boo I'm okay all right do I have oh no
I'm about
oh no am i run out of what oh okay that
open the door on the other side
huh
huh huh okay summoning circle okay
might be getting towards the end of this
I don't know
summoning circle seems kind of final
loading there we go oh I'm out of oil
waste so much oil
hello chairs you're all staring at me
ominously ah underground action looks
kinda like reminds me a PIN number a bit
well no anybody home
ah I'll see you that rock looks very
rough
yes sure does what Rock oil oil is gonna
be gone in 3 2 1
[Music]
but I did that that was me
mummers whatever you wanna call it
that rock looks very rough what Rock
what rock come here yeah let me at the
rock Oh No I see them I see you gonna
yeah
[Music]
uh-huh yeah yeah nothing nothing how
could there be nothing yeah that was
actually it going I should have just let
it go
[Music]
ah huh clothes that are
huh-huh-huh-huh-huh so dark I can't see
here we go uh-huh oh it's so dark
what's that uh-oh
[Music]
why don't candles do anything well has
that always been there all right okay ah
what
what I didn't see anything
let's do dark
I have no oil please oil no I can't see
anything
oh so dark oh oh thank you I'll but I
got to be careful about it what did I
see what happened what was scary what
was scary if I shouldn't be asking what
was scary I want to know no I don't want
to know what's in here
okay that's locked some rock looks very
rough or something
take whoa yeah that's what I wanted take
that rock huh
rock anyone Rock know what Rock looks
rough something that I'm supposed to
ease these shovels because they wouldn't
have as many shovels to dig some Rock
I'm confessed maybe something in here
mm-hmm take this rock like this and that
and some of that notice how much a
braver one now that I've got a oil huh
what the hell what what shuttle what
what shuttle top shuttle what it was in
this room nothing
he's a whole lot nothing violin where
was the rock rough
sit in that other room ah something
where the rocks look rough in this
corner oh no you want for me okay um
well no that's not it either
where'd I have the right idea don't I it
has to do with these shovels but I just
I don't see where they want me to shovel
rock looked rough I get that yeah
take that door take some shovel action
ah lever you out of there no well that's
it then
ooh what's this a powder and Mo oh it's
a cannon yeah rock rock for cannonball
that's what I'm supposed to do the where
is the gunpowder see there's rocks on
the ground but it won't let me pick it
up that's all okay let me look for some
gunpowder you gotta be some no I
wouldn't have seen it
rope nope no guy got my way I'm not
scared of you oh what's here and
anything in that pail nope
anything under this mattress oh yes
there was powder um great okay okay now
I just need a rock or a cannonball I
guess but a rock would probably do fine
no oil left in there Oh Oh No okay um
actually that's gonna have to wait until
next time I'm out of time for now thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye